when you were first getting started this
business no one knew who you were a very
young man you came out with a comedy
album the button-down mind of Bob
Newhart this is when comedy albums were
massive massive they could make a career
overnight yours went to knit since 1960
yours went to number one I think we have
a picture of the album and this is this
was I mean this was an absolute smash it
was beating some of the biggest record
recording stars at the time is that
right yeah it's the first time a comedy
album ever went to number one on the
Billboard charts and and the album that
year the album that year went to number
one and it became album of the year easy
and then then I made a second album and
that went to number two and then then
the second album went to number one and
the first album went to number two mm-hm
and my daughter who's in was in the
record business said that that's a
record that no one had for like 30 weeks
until it was broken by Axl Rose was
broke about that record was broken many
many years later by acts by Axl Rose
from Guns N'Roses number one and of
course you hate to lose the record but
at least it went to a friend
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you